des travaux d'envergure aux à lui et le
roi la commune yvelinoise 2258 habitants
est en train de refaire son centre
village autour de la mairie
le projet prévoit notamment une
bibliothèque et une grande salle
d'exposition
ça existait mais en dehors du village à
l'extrémité or le but là c'est de faire
des rencontres avec les nouveaux
habitants créer de la vie un projet
historique à 1.5 millions d'euros
presque inimaginable pour le village
pour concrétiser le dossier le maire a
fait appel à un ingénieur et un
organisme créé par le département des
yvelines en 2014 qui aide les petites
communes dans la mise en place de
projets ici la structure a permis de
réduire les frais un des rôles très
important qu'a joué
nv néron c'est justement la recherche de
toutes les subventions qui nous ont
permis de nous aider à supporter
financièrement ce projet est donc c'est
une somme de subventions qui se monte à
850 mille euros la ville d alu et laura
n'est pas un cas isolé au total 380
projets à plus ou moins grande échelle
sont attachés à ingénierie aujourd'hui
sur le département
on a participé à la construction de
bâtiments d'équipements publics de
gymnase de skate park e2 d'écoles de
logements de rénovation de mary
rénovation de deux de maison des
associations on intervient à la fin sur
bâtiments comme sur la voirie comme sur
le patrimoine
le patrimoine du bus du département
étaient rattachés cette année ingénierie
ce qui fait qu'on balaye désormais à peu
près tous les domaines de la ruralité
un concept qui fonctionne cinq ans après
son lancement 170 communes en zone
rurale ou de moins de 2000 habitants
sont adhérentes à ce projet inédit en
ile de france
il faut savoir que de temps en temps
quand on intervient intervient dans les
communes qui ont 6 ans habitant 4 100
200 300 c'est à dire que le montant du
projet qu'il souhaite et largement
supérieur au montant de leur propre
budget donc il faut trouver les
financements il faut les aider si on
n'est pas là ils ne peuvent pas monter
le projet parce qu'il est beaucoup plus
cher par rapport à leur budget
d'investissement par exemple donc c'est
là où le département et la région
également interviennent pour financer
tous ces projets en 2019 une 10
deux projets va sortir de terre grâce à
l'aide de l'organisme certains sont en
cours de finalisation c'est le cas aux
loges en josas la ville de 1600
habitants vient d'inaugurer une halle
sportive un mini terrain de football et
un skate park seul aménagement paysager
doit être terminée à partenariat conclu
en selon la mairie qui pourrait être
renouvelée dans le futur bien sûr on va
relever cité une générique on a
notamment un travail en cours sur notre
église et ses on a déjà commencé à
travailler avec dessus et
on continuera effectivement allé
solliciter le département encore chaque
année 800 mille euros ingénierie
auxquels il faut rajouter les adhésions
des communes et villes doit débourser
entre 70 centimes et 1 euro par habitant
pour être rattaché à l'organisme